and the seniors round
four
games
round five games i should say
two games are underway right now so
dmitry guravich and guess what
this is fantastic this is the
championship game between larry and
shybala who wrote the script the script
who writes the script
and they're they're underway the winner
of this game will be our senior champion
the other game doesn't really count that
uh
much for our uh
uh
perhaps it's mainly for the the prize
money yes the placement exactly exactly
i do apologize because i don't have um
the games transmitted we'll use the
bird's eye view oh and what we've got
oh we do i
just came up
oops sorry it's quite a lot of fun right
right
okay there we go i've got it yay thank
you dorisa of course i mean
between you and alejandro i would
i would be hopeless no bishop a6
targeting this pawn on c4
okay
knight to b fight no knight to d2 sorry
just defending the pawn and
intimating that in the very near future
he will have to move b2 b3 to reinforce
this pawn on c4
and the c8 if you're going to reinforce
the pawn now would be a good time to do
some pressure on that justifies that
justify the devil's advocates please so
if these gentlemen draw
then they would go into blitz
[Music]
but nobody else can catch them no they
they'll be playing just between
themselves so no more three-way ties or
no more five ways three games that's it
that's it
this is it
the game that decides
the champions the irony of the oh this
invites 95 and 93. the irony is that
larry last year
was in a playoff with gregory kaidonov
yup and he finds himself in yet another
playoff uh i was advocating right here
for the move b2b3 symptoms that is an
invitation that shabalov immediately
accepts but with this move rook e1 what
i don't like is
the very move that was played 95 and now
knight d3 yeah and wait a minute
uninvited guests i don't like i mean
they just show up guys i mean that is
there anything that's a big piece is
there any sacrifices on f2
knight to d3 thinking about f one knight
knight takes f2 yep that looks pretty
good there's no knight g4 at the end
though no i understand i have bishop c5
i mean i would be thinking about this
yeah d5 and let's go but i don't know
i'll just take the dark square bishop if
you really want to do this before all
right
which is a bit strange right because now
what if i go queen to c2
well maybe that oh then your queen is in
front of my rook maybe i can do funny
business with d5 or b5 or e well we're
about to see it he's probably going to
go for it but if you do that then a3
will come on the board exactly oh and by
the way i think we have b5 but doesn't
that invite a3 yes it does
isn't that a problem as well yes it is i
think that's a problem because if you
take on c3 i take with the queen and
that targets the knight on e5
yeah can we just pull the bishop back or
to d6
to just protect the knife it feels like
i'm the one making the right moves while
i don't know you again you have put your
your queen
vis-a-vis uh the rook in
so you're saying the queen on c2 doesn't
actually help me right i've kind of
tricked you if you will into playing the
move uh queen to c2 because basically
a move ago you know you you play the
meroxy bind why
why is the pawn on c4 and e4 good i'm
stopping d5 yes
but if i don't stop b5 as well
then i'm ending up just
not having the meroxy bind and if you
take on b5 d3 is weak
one thing that might be
tempting at this point is f4 but i think
after knight g4 you might be in deep
right you're asking for real issues with
queen b6 check maybe even queen b6 first
and then to g4 yeah this is not not the
way to play don't thought you have pawn
so the knight on e5 is annoying at f4 i
assume you want to kick that knight away
so and the c4 pawn seems to be a little
bit of a gonzo so can we just go knight
f3 and get rid of that knight well then
you're going to sacrifice upon it
exactly i mean i feel like i'm losing
that pawn anyways this way i might be
able to at least get rid of well thank
you
i believe my math is correct
the situation knight takes yes my math
is correct uh not only that this is for
the championship but this is also a
seven thousand dollar swing rapid game
again first place i always remember the
first prize twenty thousand twenty five
twenty twenty a lot more than i remember
the second prize what was the second
prize i guess it was 13
18. so that's your seven that's right
let me actually confirm that for you
that was uh well calculated that is a
well
calculated we got a 7 000 up for grabs
here
and uh
shabalov has just played this move
bishop b7
which is an indication he's ready to
play the move d5 as well as a5 and he's
cruising right now
uh larry has really butchered his
opening
with this rook e1 move i mean extra pawn
i understand you're going to do you
should be to try to get something on the
long diagonal but save king save king
not even
four he goes
bishop f4 okay just simply d6 right well
rook d1 and then queen
b6 or queen to c7 even no queen 267
knight to b5 so i cannot do that the
move that has my attention
is a5 i want to create a weakness on the
a3 pawn d6 was played on the d7 d6
inviting rook d1 so we're being told
that this is even worse actually because
second place through the fifth actually
share everything so this is actually an
eleven thousand dollar game
oh wait wait misinformation this
so the
the playoff is for first place yes stuff
stuff and that's what i also for free
yes yes yes whoever wins twenty thousand
walks home with twenty thousand and
everybody else shares everybody else
gets second through fourth
eleven thousand dollar
game right here and larry christensen is
upon down
big big trouble right now everybody else
is gonna get nine thousand dollars yes
so dimitri gets nine thousand
and so on and so on and uh
the loser of this game will likewise get
nine thousand dollars seems a little
unfair since both of these guys are
playing more
wow
they're working harder than the guys who
are in the clubhouse
nice
they're actually uh kopian is still
playing against maxwell that's true
pardon me they're not in their own play
they're going at each other you fight
hard in that game as well we're not
going to look at that but they are going
at each other because we i i bespoke
their badly yeah your queen b6 was
played too
i don't know if that was mine oh well
christian actually on a very very rare
occasion
does occasionally occasionally come up
with something really good one more
occasion yeah and one more occasion um
queen a6 looks a little awkward
but queen is
i'm worried about the a7 pawn
that was why i wanted to play a5
earlier just so yourself you saw five
steps ahead when we were really but i
just like the idea of playing for a
weakness on a3
and now we're going to have a3 a4 on it
before he's on the board i don't know
about that queen on a6 it looks
very peculiar this is a great impression
on me 97 is on the board exactly b5 okay
we're going to see
a5 queen
why
why why did he play b5 right right
knight b5 i understood you'd be hitting
oh
it doesn't queen have to go all the way
back to some place but that's okay i go
queen sees that one that's actually the
sleeve right
no the move b5 gave up the c5 square
gave up the a5 square i despise that
move i i agree
knight
boy showing oh pardon me knight 35 there
is a bishop bishop there is a bishop
hanging he's eyeballing the d3 square
but it was actually the bishop on
the same knight who we were talking
about knight d3 going to c7 bishop to e3
is on the board right now into c7 bishop
to e3 targeting that one on a7 but now
just simply bishop to a8
a6
any takers a6 b6
i don't know okay good point
i like it
bishop a8 yep
you were right just because you don't
have a5 right now well you do but that
exchange is another part at some moment
i do believe the move d6 d5 i was
looking at f5
[Music]
open up the long diagonal a queen
landing on b7 it's good to be there you
like them apples oh very much
crunchy
bishop f4 one of the things i'm never
afraid of in a hedgehog is bishop f4
takes e5 it's like go ahead make my day
take that knight and open up the bishop
on e7
um i think this is all
all shabbal off at this moment yeah it
feels in the past
f5 is on the board beautifully done
opening up that long diagonal queen b7
would be a hallelujah
something i feel like oh larry
larry is getting it's getting worse and
worse i i'm not 100 sure about that for
shabala for for larry i think larry's
position is toast yeah yeah bishop c5 is
coming
those two bishops are so strong right
now and he played rook f1
bishop to f1
he's trying to get the bishop to g2 well
can i just act with my other bishop f4
f4 bishop c5 hinting at bishop c5 next
followed by bishop to d4 so f4 is on the
board bishop to h3 tackling that pawn on
e6 okay i can defend with rook f6 which
hit it that is that's an easy one
and by the way
intimating it's time to double the rooks
on the on the f file at some point you
will have to go g4 as white well i'm
thinking bishop c5 when it lands
you're right you're gonna have to play
g4
and uh well let's play right now a
threat is to actually take on g3 first
and then go bishop to c5 agreed agreed
so that is it might be the time to go g4
he goes on
f3 i can't i just go bishop c5 check
just for the
well
i mean i take on g3 and i go group f8
right that's probably how do you deal
with
g2 is the only way out bishop to g2 but
then the g3 pawn
is tender also bishop to c5 and rook to
h6 wait a minute
are you slowly getting checked no
actually
g2 is game over after bishop c5 yeah
it's nice so how do you defend f3 you
don't good
how did he play what did he do he he
tries with rook to f1 but
inviting oh
that's okay you can take only six
even though i can even start with queen
to b6 first right
queen b6 king g2
you haven't made
a winning impression yet
what is their times
larry has three minutes and four seconds
chabot is four minutes 34 seconds and
what about rook g6 just immediately oh
he pardoned me uh the idea is if you go
king to h2 i could go rook h king g2 was
played all right
bishop h4 bishop h4 bishop g4 maybe and
then
h5
he's going for it he's done it he's done
it oh knight to e2 after bishop to h4 oh
of course much stronger wait a minute
okay that that the pieces are starting
to look a little right they're kind of
drifting to discombobulated yeah i'm i'm
so afraid of that word by the way but
it's just kind of related
you you say discombobulated i say
discombobulated right which one is the
correct one discombobulated means messed
up
you're all messed up so when i say out
of harmony that's kind of the same thing
yeah yeah we'll give you a pass thank
you
eight seven h6 i think this is an
indication that
shibalov isn't
fully
go a little yeah
a5 whoa
larry if there's an active move in the
position
he'll do it a5
that would have been on my radar
my goodness bishop e3
i'm a little bit worried with the bishop
on g4 that there's going to be a rook
takes g4
and a bishop takes e4 sighting
careful spiny senses are tingling it's
because the queen moved away from c2
right spidey senses are tingling there's
something in the air right queen to c5
okay he's getting ready to take on g4
that's the problem how do we deal with
ready
he knows it too larry knows that rook g4
is on
shabba's
everything to play for right now and
this it does seem like shabbat has this
one in the back right now right
he only needs to maintain precision
and he will take home the championship
and now he's reaching for his bishop
bishop h3
and look back bishop back larry says
draw
you know what i would do oh i was going
to say i would bring rook to g6 bishop
h3 h5 just to take away that g4 square
he wants to make sure
he wants your h5 but he's just going g6
h5 g6 now the problem is
for
larry
these rooks
specifically the rook on d1
needs
needs to roll and b5 is hanging and is
this game over guys uh
why the time
the time one minute and 35 seconds for
larry three minutes and 40 for shamalov
is it time for a move like queen b2 just
quickly done what does that do it passes
just says go ahead hit me with h5 i'll
go bishop h3 and then i take on f3
exactly and and that is the breakthrough
because e6 is hanging with a check
oh that doesn't fight h5 that helps
that does invite h5 it oh it invites
bishop takes e4 as well it's giving
black a lot of options i would just go
for h5 just keep things nice steady
just just kick that bishop away yeah
this is a way h5 this is completely with
impression and larry realizes the moment
he sees bishop e4 and i think he saw it
he just kind of like
uh the other game just finished in the
draw so
and you can also just start with h5 and
then take on e4 just so that you have
this extra h6 square for the king
yep nice yup you're right that's just
useful it's
it in case you give some checks bishop
take c6 and then i can go king g7 rook
d7 king h6 and escape exactly
he's done it just as you prescribed the
ship takes if it follows up with bishop
takes c4 yeah oh
technical
g7 but is that too much because now you
have bishop to g2 finally king h2 had a
purpose exactly
exactly well oh geez he's really trying
to create a masterpiece with this one
okay g5 are we going g4 h4 rook h6 rook
everything everything you said he's got
to go g4 f4 h4 that's okay
g6 my goodness i was sure we were gonna
hide ourselves on h6 i thought so too or
rook to f7 wow b6 let's go oh
he's
he's erring a little bit right now
[Music]
okay the threat of b7 kind of provokes
bishop to be bishop to c6 yes but then i
go back
what do you mean back to d1
still number b7
i'll take that
excuse me sorry bishop to c6 i go rook
c7 what do you think exactly i'm
thinking i'm playing for g4 actually
guys
rook to c7 what do you play it's getting
maybe queen takes b6 rook takes c6 oh
exactly so okay maybe okay so then b4
then it's bishop to d4 right up to d4
that's a tempo on the queen good move
great move by shabalov
whoa and
exchange sacrifice
and i don't know guys how easy is this
right now oh e5 if queen takes bye bye
b6 i guess
then i go f4 and then i try to push like
that i i like my position
this is much better than it was five
moves ago believe it's 40 seconds for
larry and two minutes for chapala and
larry is feeling awake
larry is feeling it right oh he's an
exchange down look how far that's okay
queen to d6 are you sure he's feeling it
right now i'm telling you queen to d6
he's much happier than what he had a
couple sure i think what he had a couple
of moves ago was terrible but queen d6 i
take it and go rook
d4 perhaps
he's
he has some chances right now agreed
agreed
no question i thought he's completely
deaf
so i like that rook on f4
i love that
not that happy with the queen but i yes
i don't think a rook be d8 but i guess i
mean if you eat ponds yeah we're happy
exactly now see three nice you you you
kind of
pull
that was a check
things are getting slippery oh
larry with okay rook h4 could shut down
the activity down to h or rook f5 this
is the other way
f5 okay i like that too bishop to
no bishop to h3 or take c5 rook you kind
of induce the rook maybe to a better
square on
f5 because it is hitting the pawn on e5
now oh
look at this that's a checkmating thread
queen takes h4mate
wow wow
those long moves huh
oh wow wow i got made what a clincher
that was i i think the arbiter came and
asked and larry said i got made it
i don't know
queen h4 one of the longest moves you'll
ever see
an emotional moment beautifully done
first right now for alex shabalov who
came out of nowhere in this tournament i
have to tell you he started off slowly
but
look what he did in the last few rounds
one on demand against larry yesterday
one on demand once again against larry
today
this is just incredible chess
alex
our congratulations to the 2022 seniors
championship and if anybody ever asks
you
do you
care
about your tournament chess
the answer is yes look at his reactions
twenty thousand dollars for the
retirement our congratulations to
alexander cheval of our new season such
a wonderful event retirement at this age
no yes sir he's playing chess every
single month he's a